Son of a beach!
I’m sorry to tell you a sad whale of a tail,
hey everyone, Julia here for DNews
Recently over 200 whales washed up on a beach
in New Zealand.
They face injury and death from dehydration.
Unfortunately almost 20 died and the rescuers
have to wait until high tide to try again
to rescue the rest.
So why does this happen?
Well it seems beachings aren’t a new thing.
There’s evidence of mass beachings going
back to Aristotle.
He said: "It is not known why they sometimes
run aground on the seashore: for it is asserted
that this happens rather fre­quently when
the fancy takes them and without any apparent
reason.
Well scientists think they have a few reasons..
One idea suggests that maybe whales chase
prey and accidently get caught up in the tide.
Yet this theory doesn’t hold much water.
Too many whales end up with on a beach with
an empty stomach.
And deep sea whales are more likely to strand
themselves than those who spend more time
closer to shore, like orcas.
Maybe they’re just following their friends.
Whales are incredibly social creatures.
Perhaps one whale is sick or injured and heads
to shallow water to take refuge.
Perhaps the tide comes in and the whale winds
up on a beach.
The other animals hear its distress calls
and come to the rescue, but get stranded themselves.
Yet some genetic testing showed a diversity
in the animals and those next to each other
weren’t necessarily closely related and
they found a surprising lack of mothers for
some of the beached babies.
This suggests a lack of social cohesion perhaps
indicating a different cause.
Another reason for beachings might be toxic
algae.
A study published in the Proceedings of the
Royal Society B found repeated ancient beachings
dating 6-9 million years ago.
To explain the repeated nature of the event,
they looked to a current explanation.
Toxic algae blooms, called “red tides”
contributed to the death and washing up of
humpback whales on the coast of cape cod in
the 80s.
Another idea of repeated stranding spots,
links the coastline to the deaths.
Researchers from the University of Western
Australia, think whales echolocation can’t
see gentle sloping shores, and sometimes rough
winds or surf scramble it too.
One theory, blames us.
Evidence of sonar causing beaching started
gathering in 2000, when a sonar test by the
US Navy killed 17 whales.
A medical exam showed the sonar was so loud,
it triggered massive bleeding around the ears.
Other exams in other beachings showed of a
kind of depression sickness, just like the
bends in humans, in some whales.
A 2008 stranding of 100 melon headed whales
on a beach in madagascar was caused by high-frequency
mapping sonar systems, the animals probably
tried to avoid the weird sound so they moved
into an unfamiliar and as it turned out, unsafe
area.
whale whale whale, why don’t you check out
this video on how algae kills whales?
but before you do leave comment below.
Don’t forget to hit those like and subscribe
button and keep coming back for new episodes
every day of the week!